[Music]
on this saturday night the intense
manhunt for a quebec father
the bodies of two young girls are found
but where is their dad
the stanley cup final in the fall plus
another record of covet 19 cases in the
united states
and remembering the standoff known as
the oka crisis
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with breaking news
out of quebec
there is a tragic end to an amber alert
police confirmed they've found the
bodies of two young girls
romy and nora carpontier who went
missing this week with their father
the bodies were found near the community
of saint apaliner about 40 kilometers
southwest of quebec city
their father is now the subject of a
police manhunt
mike armstrong is following the story
for us tonight
after days of intense searching police
found one girl
then another a short while later in the
same area
then the announcement from police the
longest amber alert in the province's
history
was lifted police say the two girls were
found lifeless
six-year-old rami and eleven-year-old
nora
the search is now a manhunt frantic at
times this was video shot by a local
resident
after what he described as a sighting in
the forest
now the woods in the area are dense
police have tried to cordon off
and search the area hoping to find the
father 44 year old marten carparzii
the three had been missing since
wednesday night last seen around 8
30. the girls were believed to have been
abducted by their father and
in danger the amber alert was issued
thursday the girls were found about 25
kilometers from where they disappeared
quebec premier francois lego reacted to
the sad developments with a series of
tweets
saturday like all quebecers he says he's
shocked
calling it a national tragedy up until
this morning
we felt that there was good information
that had come in in the past
the past few days so we were really
hopeful that
those two young sisters would have been
found alive
police are asking that anyone in the
area go online to look at the photo of
the father so they know what he looks
like
and to call 911 if they see him or
anything
suspicious mike armstrong global news
montreal
toronto police say a six-month-old baby
girl and a four-year-old boy
are both expected to recover after being
stabbed
investigators say they were called to
the scene of an apartment building this
morning and found the injured children
inside
they were rushed to hospital with
serious injuries one of the children
underwent surgery today
they're both now in stable condition
their 36 year old mother
has been arrested after months of
negotiations the nhl is coming back and
it will call canada
home a return to play plan has been
ratified with toronto and edmonton
hosting as hub cities
karen lieberman reports on how the nhl
hopes to pull it off without risking the
health of its players
or the public there will be plenty of
action on the ice in toronto and
edmonton as the national hockey league
resumes its pandemic delayed season
august 1st basically you're going to
have healthy lineups
i think the guys will be energized and
certainly the fan
component will be strange for everyone
the nhl and nhl players association
announced they ratified return to play
protocols they include two hub cities in
canada where coronavirus
infection rates remain largely under
control and a four-year extension to the
current collective bargaining agreement
to get through it for the good of our
constituents and good at the game
and for the good of our fans we needed
to work together
players have until monday at 5 p.m
eastern to declare they are opting out
of the nhl's ready to play program
calgary flames defenseman travis
hammonic is putting family
ahead of the game his daughter
contracted a serious respiratory virus
last year
so he's chosen to stay out of the
program once in toronto and edmonton
players will be kept in bubbles
confined mostly to hotels and empty
arenas undergoing daily testing
no bubble is airtight leaks happen
experts from the medical community point
out while the risk may be low
should a player contract the virus the
consequences of spreading it could be
serious
what are the longer term side effects or
consequences to that individual
and now we're talking about many many
people within that bubble the pandemic
has taken a toll on tourism in toronto
so the mayor of canada's largest city is
encouraged by the financial benefit of
being a hub
you have empty hotels and hotel workers
out of work and when you have catering
companies and other people who have been
really struggling
i think it is going to make a positive
difference for fans a return to the ice
this summer
is welcome news hockey's hockey and we
want to watch hockey any time of year
don't we
yeah i'll watch 100 i'll watch from the
comfort of home
since fans are not allowed to attend the
major thing is
ask the players what's it going to be
like for them playing without any fans
cheering them on
not the most traditional playoffs karen
lieberman
global news toronto nhl athletes are
also set to make another comeback
returning to the winter olympics in both
2022 and
2026. the decision comes as part of
terms
in the tentative agreement between
league owners and players to restart
this year's hockey season
in 2018 nhl players were unable to
attend the pyeongchang olympics because
the league refused to disrupt its season
for that year the conservatives say they
won't topple justin trudeau's minority
government but they want a criminal
investigation into his family's
connection
with we charity the organization was
tapped with monitoring a 900 million
dollar grant program
now the ethics commissioner is
investigating
we believe that there is sufficient
grounds here for them to take a look at
the criminal code and take a look
at the events that have been unfolding
over the last two weeks
look we have a nearly one billion dollar
sole source contract being awarded to
an organization with direct ties to the
liberal party of canada and to
the family of justin trudeau and ties to
him himself
the charity says it paid margaret
trudeau the prime minister's mother
about 250 thousand dollars for
approximately
28 speaking engagements it also paid
alexandra trudeau
the prime minister's brother thirty-two
thousand dollars for eight appearances
we says the prime minister's wife was
paid fourteen hundred dollars for one
event
and has volunteered for many others
the prime minister is not privy to all
of the twos and froze of what his mother
is and is engaging
is or is not engaging on nor whether
she's receiving financial compensation
but the other thing i would point out
and i think it's important for your
viewers is that
a traditional conflict of interest
analysis is looking at when there's some
pecuniary gain that's being
procured usually in a business setting
this is a not-for-profit organization
that we used
we were proposing to use to administer a
program
and you can get more details tomorrow on
the west block i'll be sitting in for
mercedes stevenson
for the first time since the pandemic
began the u.s
president has worn a mask in public
donald trump visited a military hospital
in maryland this afternoon
he was accompanied by military leaders
and staff all
wearing masks face coverings are
mandatory inside the hospital when safe
social distances cannot be maintained
trump has previously declined to wear
masks
the president's change of heart comes
after the u.s broke another daily record
for new coven 19 cases
more than 70 000 people tested positive
in one day florida south carolina
mississippi and texas are all reporting
bed shortages in intensive care
there's growing concern the increase in
hospitalizations
could lead to a spike in deaths as
jennifer johnson explains
more than half the states are now
rolling back or putting their ease back
plans
on hold as the u.s hits another record
high for new cases of covet 19.
disney world known as the most magical
place on earth reopens in hard hit
florida
limited tickets are sold out through
july the theme park closed 16 weeks ago
losing about 4 billion dollars it was a
little strange i mean because
you're so used to seeing all the cast
members and their smiles and everything
the hospitalization rate in florida has
broken a state record
at least seven hospitals in south
florida are out of icu beds
getting used to medicine texas arizona
and south carolina
have all seen their death tolls from
coven 19 rise by more than
100 percent in the past four weeks one
in five people hospitalized with a virus
in south carolina is
under the age of 30. one of our patients
that was the sickest for
the longest period of time and had gone
through
so much he was an otherwise healthy
person
young and still didn't survive this
the situation is so dire in california
the governor is releasing 8
000 prisoners early to prevent outbreaks
we're evaluating
every prisoner for release that they are
on a pathway to rehabilitation
that they are non-violent non-sex
offender
in dozens of states people who want to
get tested for the virus are forced to
wait for hours
results taking up to 10 days to get back
in iowa there are no tests available
the state has run out of them we tried
to get a test wednesday
and it said that there was nowhere not
anywhere in the state of iowa over a
dozen states have paused or rolled back
their reopenings
bars in las vegas are the latest to take
the hit forced to close again
we have followed the rules every step of
the way just not there
u.s president donald trump insists
things will be under control quickly
but a new abc news ipsos poll shows an
overwhelming number of people are
frustrated
67 percent of americans now say they
disapprove
of how the president has handled this
pandemic
jennifer johnson global news washington
dozens of u.s marines in japan have
tested positive for kova 19.
according to local media reports about
60 people at two bases on the island of
okinawa have become infected
okinawa's governor is demanding an
explanation from the american military
about the outbreak
he's concerned the u.s may not be taking
adequate prevention measures
the japanese island is home to more than
25 thousand
american troops tropical storm faye has
now weakened into a post-tropical
cyclone
but the system is still causing chaos
along the u.s east coast
fay made landfall yesterday in new
jersey packing powerful winds and
lots of rain the storm flooded streets
and shut down local beaches
faye is now heading north it's expected
to bring heavy rainfall to southern
quebec today
before dissipating tomorrow in south
africa at least five people are dead
after a hostage crisis at a church
local police say they found four bodies
in one car and the body of a security
guard in another
officers then rescued men women and
children who had been held hostage
and appeared to be living at the church
more than 40 people have been arrested
it's believed the attack was motivated
by an internal feud between
church members still to come the lessons
from the oka crisis
today marks the 30th anniversary of the
beginning of the oca crisis
what started with the proposed expansion
of a golf course west of montreal
turned into a 78-day standoff that has
left a permanent mark on canada
as dan spector reports decades later the
issues that launched the crisis
still aren't resolved
the oka crisis may be 30 years in the
past
but the message from the mohawk people
of ghana satage
remains the same land back we want our
land back
in the spring of 1990 mohawks erected a
barricade in a wooded area called the
pines
protesting the proposed expansion of a
golf course by the town of oka
onto ancestral native lands on july 11
1990 provincial police moved in to break
up the blockade
a firefight ensued and 31 year old
corporal marcel lemay was killed
a 78-day standoff between mohawks the
police
and the canadian army began ellen
gabriel was there
it was the women that went to the front
and we weren't armed we had our hands in
the air
and this swat team was was pointing
their weapons at our heads and our
hearts
this anniversary of the oka crisis
looked different than past
commemorations
instead of going through oka on foot
because of the pandemic demonstrators
stayed in their cars
we decided that it wouldn't be such a
good idea to have a march
because of the urge to to get close to
each other
so we did a rolling blockade ndp leader
jug meat singh was on hand to show his
support
so was winnipeg mp leah gazzan what
happened on this land
was in a lot of ways the beginning of a
powerful movement
many movements have been inspired by the
the incredible activists the community
the people who stood up to defend their
land
we talk in this country about
reconciliation
and there will never be reconciliation
in canada
in the absence of justice and even
though the golf course development was
eventually canceled
the land struggle has never been
resolved this is
intolerable the rolling blockade passed
through a housing development mohawks
have been denouncing for years
under canada's constitution prime
minister justin trudeau could intervene
and stop
all development that's taking place here
and he refuses today many in the mohawk
community say they want the issue of the
land
given more attention than the standoff
it created and i want people to remember
that we are the peaceful ones that the
state has always been the one
that has initiated the violence against
us the inspector global news
connection still ahead remembering the
massacre at cebanica
why families are still waiting for
justice
you're watching global national
a ceremony was held in
bosnia-herzegovina today to mark the
25th anniversary of the srebrenica
genocide thousands of muslim men and
boys were killed by serb forces on this
day in 1995
near the end of bosnia's war thousands
of survivors normally take part in the
service but because of the pandemic
only a small number attended
ceremonies were also held in canada to
mark this grim anniversary
more than 25 thousand canadians claim
bosnian descent and many of them arrived
in this country
during or shortly after the bosnian war
as mike delay explains they came here
hoping to find a better life the photo
is
faded and well worn much like the
memories marella hojicevic has of her
father suleiman
one of over eight thousand victims in
what's become known
as the srebrenica massacre he was a few
days short of turning
27. was making a desperate attempt to
escape
the bosnian serb forces who were
rounding up and summarily executing
muslim boys and men
it would be nine years before his
remains were found in a forest grave
and when i would go to sleep at night i
would actually
imagine the scene of him coming back i
think my mom
she actually knew that he would never
come back but she never wanted to tell
us
by then marella had emigrated to canada
with her mother and brother
she was the only one who spoke english
it was up to her to do the interview
with immigration
and to set up bank accounts she was 12.
yeah well it was really really difficult
but canada has
given us an opportunity to change our
destiny
and we have definitely changed murder
extermination a quarter century after
srebrenica
history shows that 62 bosnian serbs were
convicted of war crimes
yet survivors are still waiting for the
bosnian serb republic to own up to
charges of genocide
and the forcible rape of thousands of
muslim women
it's those denials that spurred windsor
mp brian massey
whose visit to the mass graves left him
shaken to erect a monument in his
hometown
you know hopefully sometime during the
year somebody will walk by and they'll
see
you know they'll see the memorial and
they'll ask questions about the lookout
in line and then they'll remember
and find out what took place and that's
one person stronger
for the international community
including canada this anniversary is a
reminder
of failure u.n troops witnessed the
massacre unfold yet were vastly
outnumbered and unable to stop it
i think one of the legacies has been
that uh countries have learned not to
get involved because once you're
involved you're responsible so
take a look around the world canada is
not involved much peacekeeping
because they don't want to be present
where war crimes are happening and they
don't want to have their troops at risk
last year during a visit to bosnia
marella's five-year-old daughter miriam
asked to learn more about her
grandfather
and what life was like for marella at
the same age
it's not a story any child should know
much less live through
microlight global news toronto
up next the mass infestation that's
threatening millions of lives
swarms of locusts have been devouring
crops across much of east africa
it's the worst infestation seen in the
region in decades and is part of a wider
problem across many parts of western
asia and india but in the horn of africa
the swarms are threatening to make a
food insecurity situation
even worse here's redmond shannon
millions and billions of them desert
locusts
devouring crops threatening livelihoods
and potentially lives you'll find that
almost all the tomatoes have been
destroyed in this shape so
this is a loss that we are we are
encountering at the moment
the desert locust is normally a harmless
dull grasshopper but under certain wet
weather conditions
it makes a jekyll and high
transformation into this
ravenous yellow swarmer two cyclones in
the indian ocean in 2018
triggered highly unusual rains in remote
areas of the arabian peninsula
swarms multiplied and moved northeast to
iran
pakistan and india and south to
war-ravaged yemen
and eastern africa they are areas where
tens of millions of people
are already facing the threat of hunger
east africa
you know is extremely vulnerable they've
had three years of droughts they have
this year now
floods and and and and heavy rains
um so you know they're already um kind
of
very sensitive to any additional shocks
that might occur
there's a swarm um earlier this year in
northern kenya
that was 60 kilometers long and 40
kilometers wide
the summer breeding season will see the
problem increase
the weather could determine if this
becomes a full-blown locust plague
so an upsurge is kind of regionally
based on you know what we're seeing now
in east africa
but you know a plague then would be
basically from from west africa all the
way across to to southwest asia
the united nations is raising funds to
spray millions of hectares with
pesticide
some indian authorities are using drones
as an alternative to kill the locusts
but the chemicals can harm the
environment and other insects
scientists in kenya are developing bio
pesticides
and even agents that confuse locusts
into eating each other
they are also advocating that people
start eating them too
we think it's something to promote so
that a lot more people should engage
in this in this practice rather than
shine away thinking that it is a
primitive
man's food poetic justice perhaps but
something that would barely make a dent
in this
enormous threat redmond shannon global
news london
a cat who disappeared 18 months ago in
victoria bc
is back with his family and has quite
the tale to tell
who is that
this is the moment blue was reunited
with the owens family
and seven-year-old hayden he was
discovered on july 2nd
17 kilometers away from home he hadn't
been spotted since december of 2018.
it took about four hours a few traps and
some motion sensor cameras but blue was
scooped up the next day
blue has lost a few pounds but he is
sure making up for it now with unlimited
treats
and cuddles as he gets used to his
surroundings
the cat always comes back and that is
global national for this saturday i'm
robin gill tonight your canada is out of
this world it's comet
neowise flying over abbotsford bc bright
and early this morning
hope to see you back here tomorrow
everyone good night
[Music]